(camera and mic noises)
- What up vlog?
Kind of interesting day.
Heading to the airport,
heading to Seattle.
Good day in L.A., bunch of meetings.
Kind of helter skelter day,
I don't even really know what you got.
- We're at the CBS lot, Gary
just ran in for a meeting,
can't film.
- Theme today, real
simple, lot of judgment,
just a lack of perspective in the system.
Just a lot of judgment out there.
The abundance of opportunity is something
I'm thinking a lot about.
People keep thinking that
if somebody gets something
it comes out of them.
Which is ridiculous.
I just think people are short-term.
Short-term mentality my friends.
Life is long.
Just impatience, insecurity,
it's all the themes man,
this is a mindset game.
I'm just trying to put out
positivity and practicality.
Which is like empathy.
People are confused, a lot of confusion.
But, there's just so much good I'm seeing.
Like everyday hundreds of emails,
DMs of people getting inspired
finally go into action.
And the principles, this is a marathon.
I don't know what episode this is,
what are we in the 400's now?
- [Driver] This'll be 460 something.
- Same shit.
460 something.
46, fourth episode and 4,067.
It's all gonna be the same shit.
Unless you get your
operating system, your dome,
your mindset into a balanced place,
you're gonna struggle.
You're gonna be off center.
And so I just wish you
guys so much happiness
and that starts within.
And that starts real light.
Like if the voice in your head isn't good
and isn't secure or you
don't love yourself,
you've just got to understand
that that was put in your head
by somebody, by something,
and you need to kick it the fuck out.
And my mission is to help
you kick it the fuck out.
So grinding, got a lot done.
Was at William Morris working
on some projects there.
Was in the studio working
Just had a meeting with Ryan
Fage executive from Vainer.
Working on Vainer L.A.
Just Rich Eisen, some good content there.
We can't have kids who live in Miami
walking around with Steph Curry jerseys.
- [Rich Eisen] Why?
- I don't like this
thing that is underlining
which is young children,
and grown men and women,
are using sports teams
to subsidize their lack of self esteem.
They think that putting on a
Tom Brady jersey in Minnesota
means they're winning.
I need a news alert for everybody.
That team is winning.
You're not a winner.
You root for a winner.
Just doing my thing.
Trying to figure it out.
We're going to the airport right?
- [Driver] You're going through this thing
called a private suite.
- Oh I got some sort of thing?
- [Driver] Yeah.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Driver] You have to go
here and I have to go back.
- Got it.
Private suite.
Don't be fancy until you're fancy.